This is the child's top we're working on.
We click on it, it brings it up here.
Are we sure this is the one we want?
Okay, we can use click on this.
Let's say piece block, make a new piece.
And I'm going to call this pocket.
Okay.
And now I have a very big pocket.
Let's say centralize.
All I have a very big pocket.
I'm working in centimeters.
I'm going to say this
icon here, fit to length.
I'm going to make this 10
CM high and fit to width.
I'm going to make this twelve
and a half centimeters wide.
Turn the numbering off, turn the vertical
mirror off so that it's not so busy.
We could even take this with our right
mouse button and we could lay it out
on top of this front garment piece to see
if this is something that we're
going to like as far as the size.
And let's move it off here and select
the front as the active garment piece.
Again, notice if it's in white,
it's the active piece.
The gray piece originated
in standard garment styling.
And this pocket was never standard garment
styling, it was only original
pattern drafting piece.
We're going to say centralized piece.
And we're going to use this icon here.
And we're going to say measure
the edge from here to here.
And it's 22.4. We're going
to say hang a marker.
And it has a marker
here and a marker here.
And designing it eight automatically
puts a marker at the armhole edge.
So that when you're knitting,
interactively knitting,
you knit all the way up to here.
And it gets to this row
and it says set a marker.
This marker also works in several
of the printouts so that you can use them
for blocking or you can use the extra
points with markers for seaming
them together accurately.
Let's turn the markers off
and let's say measure edge again.
And if I click on the first of this pair,
it gets rid of it and I'm going to say
undo because I want that information.
We're going to make a child's top address
and what I want to do is I want
to make it this into a Bodice.
So I'm going to make it 7.5 CM.
That's three inches for the Bodice.
Four -7.5 is 14.9 this button here is
insert and I'm going to insert length.
Right here between these two points
and I'm going to enter in instead
of a positive number a negative number
to get it to not insert points
but to subtract fabric.
And here's my 7.5 centimeter Bodice.
If you're working normally,
working inches, you can say options,
units of measurement.
And tell me about this in inches.
And it's 2.9 inches.
Let's go back to centimeters,
which as I usually work in,
we can also say stitches and rows.
Okay.
And it says here from here to this.
Let's turn the point numbering on this is
point number ten from here
to here is 29 rows.
So we'll going to get up to here
and then the marker is going to be here.
And it's going to tell
us to set the marker.
Now they're going to say
centralized all the pieces.
We need to do the same thing.
For the back, we're going to say insert
length and we're going to say negative
14.9. Okay,
we're going to move to the back and we're
going to say option units of measurement
that we want to work in normal units,
not stitches and rows.
And remember, when we measured this,
we said from here to here.
Clockwise is 22.4 CM, this icon here.
And I'm going to do it in between point
eight, point nine, and I'm
going to say -14.9 point.
Okay.
Now I have two pieces for the bodice.
And I have long sleeves and I
have a pocket for the dress.
If I say measure this edge,
measure edge from zero nine to 00:10,
it says it's 39 CM across.
If I say options, units of measurement,
stitches and rows.
Okay, it's saying that it's 107 across.
And if I double that,
that more than a needle bed can hold.
We have 200 stitch designer needle bed.
This is going to be more then we need 14
more stitches than we have
available on our needle bed.
So we're going to knit this dress in two
pieces and seam them together
and put them together.
The other option is to change
the tensions, option tensions.
And we can use a different kind of yarn or
we can use a different
dial setting on our yarn.
And let's say it's 25 and 38 rows.
Okay?
97.0 stitch designer.
If I double that, it come out with 194.
And that works fine on my needle bed.
So let's make sure that we have
a gauge for our tension swatch.
That is the tension that we
just changed it to.
I need to say piece block,
make a new piece.
And I'm going to call
this one dress front A.
Okay, we know that this
is 97 stitches across.
Let's go back and change this units
of measurement to normal units.
Okay, this is 39.
We're going to knit this in one piece.
So 39 and 39 is 78 CM wide.
And so I'm going to say
fit to width this time.
And I wanted this to be 78 CM across
and I want the length to be 50.
Let's move this sleeve out of the way
with our right mouse button.
And let's move this dress over here.
And we'll move this sleeve out of the way.
As we'll so you can see,
we still can arrange more garments.
We have up to 16 garment pieces available
to our garment shape,
which is quite a lot of piece.
If I knit this up to the top and then I
take this off on waist yarn and then put
it back, two stitches on every needle,
then I can start knitting up the bodice
and knit the bodice direction
straight up to the top.